>>> AH, COME ON NOW, JIMBO, I'M
FINE.
>> RICH, YOU KNOW I'M JUST
LOOKING OUT FOR YOU, NOW COME
ON.
GIVE ME WERE YOUR CAR KEYS, YOU
AROUND DRIVE HOME TONIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT, GOOD NIGHT FOR A
WALK HOME ANYHOW.
>> SAY, RICH, WHAT ARE YOU DOING
OUT HERE DRINKING ON CHRISTMAS
EVE?
AIN'T YOU GOT NO FAMILY?
>> FAMILY?
WHO NEEDS FAMILY?
>> WHAT ABOUT THAT GIRL, DENISE,
YOU BEEN GOING AROUND WITH?
WHY AREN'T YOU WITH HER?
>> CALLED THAT WHOLE THING OFF,
JIMBO.
YOU KNOW ME, I'M A LONE WOLF.
THAT'S THE WAY I LIKE IT.
>> TRYIN' MY BEST, BOSS.
TRYIN' MY BEST.
>> FAMILY.
WHO WOULD WANT TO GET TIED DOWN
TO SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
NOT ME, I TELL YOU.
NO SIRREE.
♪ ♪
LOOK AT THEM.
SO MUCH LOVE.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN AFRAID OF
ALL THESE YEARS.
SO BEAUTIFUL.
>> STEVEN, THERE IS A MAN
STARING AT US THROUGH OUR
WINDOW.
>> YES, I SEE HIM TOO.
JUST STAY CALM.
ACT LIKE HE ISN'T THERE.
HE'LL LOSE INTEREST, AND HE'LL
LEAVE.
>> I SPENT MY WHOLE LIFE
RUNNING, AND FOR WHAT?
JUST TO BE ALL ALONE ON
CHRISTMAS EVE?
>> HE ISN'T LEAVING.
>> JANINE, RELAX.
>> HOW CAN I RELAX WHEN THERE IS
A PERVERT LURKING IN OUR WINDOW?
>> HE'S TRYING TO FREAK US OUT,
JANINE.
THAT'S WHAT GETS HIM OFF.
DON'T GIVE HIM THE SATISFACTION
>> OH, I SHOULD HAVE MARRIED
DENISE.
I DROVE HER AWAY.
LOOK AT YOU!
YOU MAKE ME SICK!
YOU RUINED MY LIFE!
>> DAD?
I THINK THE MAN WANTS TO KILL
ME.
>> STEVEN, HE IS SCARING OUR
CHILDREN.
STOP JUST SITTING THERE AND BE A
MAN.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT, JANINE?
>> I WANT YOU TO PROTECT THIS
FAMILY.
>> GO OUT THERE AND MAKE HIM
LEAVE, DAD, PLEASE!
>> I'M NOT GOING OUT THERE, ARE
YOU CRAZY?
DON'T LOOK AT HIM.
HE'LL LEAVE.
>> ARE YOU A COWARD.
>> WHAT HAVE I DONE?
WASTING YEARS AT THE OFFICE,
WORKING DAY IN AND DAY OUT!
WHAT DO I HAVE TO SHOW FOR IT?
FANCY SUIT!
SILK TIE!
>> ARE YOU HAPPY NOW?
HE IS EXPOSING HIMSELF.
>> WELL, SORRY, I DON'T WANT TO
GET KILLED, JANINE.
>> YOU ARE PATHETIC, AND THAT'S
WHY I DID WHAT I DID LAST
SUMMER.
>> WHAT HAPPENED LAST SUMMER?
>> YOUR MOTHER STEPPED OUTSIDE
OF OUR MARRIAGE.
>> WHAT?
>> GIVE ME ANOTHER CHANCE AT
LIFE.
LET ME START AGAIN AND HAVE A
PERFECT FAMILY, LIKE THIS.
>> MOM, HOW COULD YOU CHEAT ON
DAD?
>> BECAUSE I HAVEN'T BEEN
ATTRACTED TO HIM IN YEARS!
>> COME ON, RICH.
GET AHOLD OF YOURSELF.
>> KENDALL, ARE YOU AN ANGEL?
>> YEAH.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> YOU GOT TO HELP ME.
I'VE WASTED MY WHOLE LIFE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> KIDS, DON'T LOOK AT THE MAN,
DON'T LOOK AT THE MAN.
>> LISTEN TO YOUR MOTHER!
>> NOW I'LL NEVER HAVE A FAMILY.
>> I WOULDN'T BE TOO SURE OF
THAT.
>> RICH?
RICH IS THAT YOU?
>> DENISE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE?
>> OH, I WAS JUST PASSING BY.
I'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT YOU,
RICH.
>> WELL, DENISE, WOULD YOU
PLEASE TAKE ME BACK?
I'M READY TO HAVE A FAMILY NOW.
>> OH, RICH, OF COURSE I WILL!
>> NICE WORK, BOSS.
NICE WORK.
>> I THINK HE'S LEAVING.
>> YEAH, YEAH, GET OUT OF HERE,
BEAT IT!
YOU HEAR ME?
SEE, I GOT RID OF HIM.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ANYMORE,
YOU'RE SAFE NOW.
>> WAY TO GO, DAD.
>> WOW, WHAT A HERO.